what kind of a differential equation
sorry what kind of function are we going
to do here so we're gonna define P as
that quantity
it's changing right and what I'm going
to demonstrate for you is that the
exponential equation a particular for
the exponential equation satisfies all
of this so let's think about growth
first how are we going to define it now
we could just start with something very
very simple like this right except this
is very specific this only works in the
exact case where the rate of change
you're growing up is exactly equal to
like this is this is the rate of change
right this is my f data column is
exactly equal to your population right
or whatever it is that you're growing
but we might be off by some kind of
close to so what would be different with
this to turn the derivative into not
exactly the same thing but a multiple of
the same thing how would I have to
change this original function it's gonna
be it's gonna be a chain rule situation
right because we're this if I slap okay
then right when I would come from is the
dude of the inside function doesn't that
make sense so I would really want okay
up there
does that make sense so I'm gonna change
one more thing as well I'm going to add
this guy on the front and I'll explain
him in second okay so what this is here
is say my population is defined as an
exponential function but I've got these
two things to muck about with number one
we've got K be positive real number this
stuff is often called the growth
constant so it defines how quickly
things are going and then you've got
this guy P which defines not how fast
you're growing but where you start right
so if you want to think about it don't
have to write this but if you wanna
think about it like a linear function
right a linear function can be
unambiguously defined by its gradient
which is how fast it's growing it's kind
of like this guy right and it's
y-intercept where it begins right where
x equals zero what are you equal to and
that's what this corresponds to okay
I suppose or another way you could write
this
is that and this is why it's called P
door right P at naught right if I put in
T time equals zero that's going to write
because what happens to this part here
the exponential part with time to zero
it just becomes one right either power
or anything to the power of not is just
one so you just get left with this guy
so that's why we designate him
P naught other times you will see it
written as this and they mean the same
thing they just substituted capital n so
what's the first letter it's way to
begin it's just the name of the cluster
okay so we want to demonstrate and this
will often be the first part of an
agency exponential growth and decay
question we just want to get this
straight like where do we plug this out
of the air frog how can we justify that
it's worth using in a situation like
this and it's very very simple to prove
that this satisfies the differential
equation all I need to do is start from
this and this tells me well if you
differentiate you ought to get something
at the other end so all I'm gonna do is
take this expression and differentiate
right so I'll take P a different shape
with respect to time okay so let's have
a look if I P naught is just any closer
I'm gonna leave that closed the
coefficient out the front what happens
when I'm differentiating e to the KT
we're just telling ya I'm gonna have the
contributor of the insight and the root
of the outside well eat or whatever just
gives you two whatever right all I do is
slightly rearrange this and you can see
tada I had that results that I was
trying to show okay so this is very
straightforward it almost seems trivial
but it's important because it's kind of
like well this is what I know where did
this come from how can you justify that
this is worth using in this kind of
situation and the answer is look if you
do this substitution it works now just
as a side note differentiation is only
one half of the calculus
right what's the other half what's the
other side appreciation its integration
right now I do not advise that you use
integration to prove that this satisfies
the differential equation because
differentiation is so simple it's so
obvious however it's still good to know
and it's not it's not hard to wrap your
head around it's just so much longer and
less efficient that you might as well
always use this but let's think about
this right how would I go about proving
that this satisfies this by using
integration instead of differentiation
what would I do
I am gonna have to shift some stuff
around one of the question really is
what function will I have to integrate
to sort of get here I can't do it give
me suggestions are you starting from
here yes you can start from here it's
fine I'm going to suggest that that if I
want to use integration not
differentiation right this is probably
not gonna be a great place to begin
right because I'm not gonna end up with
an expression with D PLDT in it am i
right
if I integrate this is no way you can
get a DP MDT I bet you're gonna get P
Prime
whatever that happens to be okay if I
want to differentiate I'm gonna start
here I'll get a DPN detail if I want to
integrate I shouldn't stop from there I
should stop from here should not this is
where I should be integrating that deep
here the T will be there and there will
be the pain that I'm after okay so
here's where I'm going to begin you can
put this on the side here and reduce by
integration step differentiation I'd
like to begin with this statement
because I know it to be true I know it
to be true now it looks a little weird
at the moment so I'm just going to
rework it so that I can integrate
according to an appropriate variable
which is the weird part watch this if I
divide through by
pay and multiply through by detail I've
told you before that's a little bit of
dicey thing to do but in this case it
will work because that DT is not hanging
there what it's only it's actually you
know a multiple of something so this is
how we do integration the areas in the
first place all I've done is just
rearrange ever so slightly he's gone
over their duties got over there but now
because I have DP here DT here I can
integrate both sides with respect to
these variables do you see that we're
used to taking two sides of an equation
that integrating with respect to the
same variable right but here the
variables of integration are already
supplied okay let's help you on the left
in time yeah whatever paid right with
respect to P that's just the derivative
of one function right the natural log
function I it's got a cluster on it but
so does the indefinite integral on the
right hand side and two clusters
together it's just one big constant or a
small constant so I'm going to leave off
the constant until I have the right-hand
side you'll see why in a second now I've
got K which is a constant what happens
when I integrated with respect to T it's
just KT and and now I'm ready to put my
constantly okay right now where am I
trying to head I'm trying to get to
something like this right last time I
started here and differentiate it and I
ended there and now I'm going in the
exact opposite direction so I started
there I'm trying to end here what should
I do
yeah so this is a long equation which we
know is just another way of free me and
exponential equation right so this is
log base E right so it means P is e to
the power of KT plus C do you agree with
that
Warners there uh no right usually my
index laws I recognize that each of a
something plus something that's actually
a product isn't it okay so I'm gonna run
it in this water cuz look look look
where I'm heading you're in great so I'm
just gonna call P no I'm just gonna call
it that this is just a
right he is a constant C is some
constant that I don't know but that must
be the starting position okay because
that when you put in time zero that's
your initial value so now you can see
why differentiation is clearly a
superior way of doing this right you
still end up with the same result by
dramatically faster you don't have to
make this reader kind of leap I mean
it's all true but there's no reason why
you wouldn't do that so much more
efficient okay so would you I believe
it's 7g 7g and let's just do one example
together so you can see the way this way
this is the same the same chapter you be
looking at the HSA yeah sure I won't do
it now I'll come and sit next to your
dirty stop so this is e to the X and you
can differentiate that does that even
found something yeah
yeah yeah you see oh sorry I forgot one
thing one more thing this is all about
girth is all about birth okay so this is
my growth equation and you can see it's
going to slightly different form but if
I want decay instead of growth remember
this is what a decay situation will
looks like okay well what's the
relationship between these two
geometrically what to the relationship
geometrically I have the horizontally
and horizontally for me in this context
means with respect to T great so all I
have to do to turn this growth equations
into a decay equation is to slap a minus
sign right there right so P equals P
naught e to the minus KT and you can see
again I can verify this very easily by
differentiation you do the inside
function will be negative K which comes
out the front everything else stays the
same
okay